[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا بدات الان مراسم تتويج
تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا دخل من
الباب العظيم الغربي ثم بدا بالسير عبر
صحن الكنيسه وصولا الى قاعتها الوسطى
وسط حضور كبير
يتعدى 2300 شخصيه تمثل 200 دوله حول
العالم من بينهم 100 زعيم ورئيس دوله
يتقدم هذا
الموكب المهيب زعماء دينيون
وممثلون عن بلدان الكومنويلث
ونشاهد كامله التي ستصبح اليوم ايضا
ملكه بعد التتويج
الاحتفال كما نتابع تتخلل مقطوعات موسيقيه
اختارها الملك بنفسه دعونا نستمع لها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا
وصل الملك تشارلز الثالث الثالث الى كنيسه
منستر طبعا
يرافق حفيد الملك الامير جورج والذي سيكون
من بين الوصفاء في الكنيسه الى جانب احفاد
الملكه القرينه كامله لولا واليسا ولوي
وفردي وسيحمل بعض المشاركين في الموكب
داخل كنيسه قطع الرجاله نستمع الى هذا
الحديث
والاعتراف
وشكره على خدمته طيله الحياه لهذه الامه
للكام
لنشهد بسعاده دهنه بالزيت وتتويجه
وسيتم تتويجه على خدمه شعبه
دعونا نعم
بعقولنا واجسادنا من اجل تجدد العقيده
وامل مليء بالسعاده والتزام لخدمه بعضنا
البعض في الحب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا كما تحدثنا فان هذه
الاحتفالات
ستتضمن مقطوعات موسيقيه اختارها الملك
بنفسه
الان مشاهدينا تبدا المرحله الاولى وهي
الاقرار والتي يتم فيها تقديم الملك
تشارلز الى الرعيه وهو تقليد يعود الى
العصور الانجلوس ساكسونيه
اتيتم اليوم لتقدموا احترامكم
وخدماتكمون القيام بالمثل حفظ الله الملك
[موسيقى]
لكم
الملككم دون ريب
انتم الذين اتيتم اليوم لتقدموا احترامكم
وخدماتكم وتنون القيام بالمثل حفظ الله
الملك تشارل
[موسيقى]
اقدم لكم الملك تشانس
ملككم دون ريب الذي من اجله اتيتم اليوم
لتقدم احترامكم وخدماتكم اتونا القيام
بالمثل
حفظ الله الملك تشانس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا المرحله الاولى
من مراسم التتويج التي ستستمر لمده ساعتين
في كنيسه وست منستر والان الاستعدادات
تبدا بعد تقديم الملك تشارلز الى الرعيه
لبدء المرحله الثانيه
من عمليه التتويج طبعا الملك تشارلز كان
يرتدي وهو يرتدي الان رداء طويل مطرز
بالمخمل القرمزي
تتلقى هذا الكتاب
عن شيء الاكثر قيمه في هذا العالم هذه هي
الحكمه
هذا هو القانون ايضا الان نحن نتابع
المرحله الثانيه من مراسم التتويج وهي
تقديم ربما القسم يقوم كبير اساقفه تلاوه
قسم التتويج وهو شرط قانوني ثم يطلب من
الملك تشارلز ان يؤكد التزامه بالقانون
وتعليم الكنيسه الانجليزيه خلال عهده
بالتاكيد سيضع الملك يده على الانجيل
المقدس ويتعهد
بتنفيذ ذلك والوفاء بهذه العهود في هذه
المرحله الثانيه
طبعا من الممكن ان يضيف الملك تشارلز
الثالث بعض الكلمات بعد هذه المرحله
الثانيه من القسم
ويعبر عن تقديره للديانات المتعدده التي
تمارس في بريطانيا
وعلى الارجح لن تكون جزء من القسم نفسه
ولم يتم تاكيد ذلك على كل حال نتابع ذلك
الان يستعد الملك تشارلز الثالث ليضع يده
كما ذكرنا على الانجيل المقدس ويتعهد
بتنفيذ تلك العهود
اذا مشاهدينا الان يتلو كبير اساقفه
قسم التتويج على الملك تشارلز الثالث وهذا
شرط قانوني وربما واحد من اهم
مراحل
مراسم التتويج
ويطلب من الملك تشارلز ان يؤكد التزامه
بكل هذه البنود وبالقانون وتعاليم الكنيسه
الانجليزيه خلال عهده
كملك رقم 40 للمملكه
المتحده وان يفي بهذه العهود
ج
اذا بهذه الكلمات قام الملك تشارز الثالث
بتلاوه القسم وهي المرحله الثانيه من
مراحل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
للمملكه المتحده
[موسيقى]
وطلب الخدمه
ارحم
من يقوم بهذه الخدمه
وفي هذه الحريه الحقيقه الساطعه امنح
النعمه لكل البشريه في كل الديانات
والمعتقدات هذا
يمكن ان يسمح لنا باكتشاف
السبيل السلام من خلال المسيح
امين
[موسيقى]
اذا قام الملك تشارلز الثالث
باداء القسم
وبتلاوه قسم التتويج وكما ذكرنا هو شرط
قانوني لاكتمال هذه المراسم
بعد قليل ستبدا المرحله الثالثه من مراسم
التتويج وهي تتعلق
بالمسح بالزيت المقدس وهذه مرحله لديها
خصوصيه كبيره
وستتم بسريه
وبعيدا عن اعين الحضور وعدسات الكاميرات
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذه المراسم كان فيها خروج واضح عن
التقاليد المتبعه
في بريطانيا مع مشاركه اساقفه نساء
وقادت ديانات اقليه
وقائمه مدعوين اكثر تنوعا وتمثيلا للمجتمع
البريطاني الذي تغير كثيرا
عما كان عليه
قبل
سنوات
الجديد ايضا في هكذا نوع من المراسم حضور
مسائل يهتم بها الملك تشارلز الثالث مثل
البيئه
[موسيقى]
وايضا
حتى مسح الملك بالزيت سيكون بزيت
خاص
والملابس سيعاد تدويرها
هذا يعكس القضايا التي حملت تشارلز لوائها
طيله حياته
وتتمحور حول الاستدامه والتنوع البيولوجي
اذا تستمر
هذه المراسم وتتخللها كما ذكرنا مقطوعات
موسيقيه
اختارها الملك تشارلز
الثالث بنفسه
ولها خصوصيه لديه
هناك ستكون مقطوعه للفنان اندرويد
وموسيقى ارثوذكسيه يونانيه احياء لذكرى
والده الامير فيليب
[موسيقى]
هذه المراسم ربما استقطبت
انذار البريطانيين
والملايين حول العالم
هذه المره الاولى التي يتم فيها تتويج ملك
في بريطانيا منذ 70 عاما
بعد وفاه الملكه اليزابيث العام الماضي
والتي تم تتويجها عام 53
اذا اليوم سيتم تتويج تشارلز الثالث ملكا
لبريطانيا
وسيصبح الملك رقم 40
[موسيقى]
هذه الكنيسه واسم الاستر شهد التتويج
كل ملوك بريطانيا الاربعين
[موسيقى]
وربما
حافظت
المؤسسه الملكيه على هذه التقاليد لعقود
طويله
[موسيقى]
والكثير من الادوات والالبسه
وايضا
المواد التي سيستخدمها كانت موجوده منذ
مئات السنين من بينها
الكرسي
الذي سيشهد تتويج الملك تشارلز
وهو يعود الى 700 عام
وتم تتويج اكثر او نحو ثلاثه وعشرين ملكا
على هذا الكرسي
الان يتحدث كبير اساقفه
استعدادا
للمرحله الثالثه
يتوقع
ان يخلع الملك
تشارلز الثالث الثالث عباءه
التي كان يرتديها
ويجلس على كرسي التتويج
الان نستمع الى كلمه رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني
سمعنا لا تتوقف عن الصلاه والرغبه انك
يمكن ان تكون مليئه بارادته الحكيمه
والروحيه
انه يمكن ان تكون جدير بالله بنعمه نكون
صادقا في كل عمل
وسعي لمعرفه الله
مع الحصول على كامل القوه حسب قوته
الالهيه وكذلك الصبر والمعاناه في كنف
السعاده وتوجيه الشكر الى الاب الذي جعلنا
نجتمع لنكون شاهدين على هذه هذا التوريس
لدينا منح لنا او لنا من الظلام والى
ملكوتي ابني في الذي
نسعى من خلال دمه
للصبح الصفح عن الخطايا
الله غير المرئي
والذي هي في الجنه وعلى الارض مرئيه وغير
مرئيه
سواء كانت
يتحدث الان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
وطبعا كلمات تحمل طابع ديني تتماهى مع
رمزيه هذه اللحظات
ومراسم التتويج لكن رغم ذلك
هذه
المراسم تمر في لحظات
ربما بريطانيا
تمر فيها باسوء ازمه معيشيه
واضطرابات واضطرابات شلت البلاد
وربما انعكست على الاحتفالات التتويج
وانتقادات رافقت هذه العمليه
[موسيقى]
ثلوجيا
اذا مشاهدينا تتواصل الان في كنيسه من
مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
هذه
المراسم مدروسه بعنايه وبدقه وتاخذ وقتا
طويلا رغما انه تم اختصار الكثير من
تواقيت وحتى مسار موكب الملك تشارلز
وذلك لاسباب تتعلق
بربما الاعمال الاقتصاديه التي قد تمثلها
مثل هذه الاحتفالات وايضا
لاسباب تتعلق بشخصيه الملك تشارلز الذي
يود ان يعكس صوره
مختلفه عن باقي ملوك بريطانيا صوره تتماها
وتتماشى مع ما كانت عليه بريطانيا وما
وصلت اليه
على كل حال ينضم الينا مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه
بعد قليل
ليطلعنا على مزيد من التفاصيل فيما يتعلق
عن هذا الموضوع لكن ينضم الينا الان
الصحفي محمد شبارو من لندن اهلا بك محمد
تتابع معنا الان
هذه المراسم والتي تخللتها الكثير من
المقطوعات وايضا الكثير من
المراسم المعروفه لو تعطينا لمحه عن ابرز
ما سنشهده بعد قليل خلال مراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث
يعني ابراهيم مرحبا بكم وبمشاهدين الكرام
كما نتابع هذه الصور التاريخيه
حاليا
هي يعني عمليه تتويج من ولد ليكون ملكا
يعني لقد عرف الشعب البريطاني تشارلز منذ
ولادته كان اميرا عصريا تدخل بكثير من
الامور تم تصويره
ومتابعه كل نشاطاته لحظه بلحظه على مدى
سبعين عاما الماضيه من عمره لكنه اليوم
يعني هو بين ايدي التقاليد والاعراف ويسير
خطوه خطوه لتنفيذ يعني عمليه التتويج
والتي نص عليها
الدستور الملكي مؤسسه الحكم الملكيه غير
المكتوبه واعرافها وتقاليدها الضاربه في
القدم
الان يعني كما نلاحظ ان هذه كما ذكرتم قد
تم التدرب على
دمج عمليه التتويج ولكن في نهايته سيبدا
ما يعرف هنا بالعهد الكاروليان عهد الملك
تشارلز الثالث
عن يعني بوجه شرعي ورسمي وحقيقي وذلك
عندها سنرى بعد المسح بالزيت المقدس سيتم
وضع
التاج التاج على راس الملك
تشارلز الثالث ليبدا ما يسمى رسميا بعهده
وطبعا ستتم سيكون هناك بيعه من الشعب
والمواطنين البريطانيين ولكن كما قلت
استاذ ابراهيم ايضا لقد تم اختصار
البرنامج ليكون اكثر عصريه لن يكون هناك
عمليات البيعه من النبلاء من الطبقه
الطبقات النبلاء في بريطانيا بل هو اعلان
عام كنا قد شهدناه قليل بان
هؤلاء يبايعونه وحده ولي العهد البريطاني
الامير ويليام امير ويلز سيقدم البيعه
لوالده وسنشهدها بعد قليل في ختام ربما
عمليه التتويج هذه
اطاله عمر العائله المالكه والعلاقات مع
اوروبا محمد ربما هي تحديات تنتظر الملك
تشارلز الثالث برايك كيف سيتعامل معها بعد
تتويجه
يعني هناك
بريطانيا ما زالت مؤيده للملكيه وفق
استطلاعات الراي جميعها تؤكد ان على الاقل
ثلثي الشعب البريطاني مع بقاء هذه المؤسسه
ثلث فقط من الشعب واغلبهم من الاجيال يعني
جيل زد ما يعرف بجيل زد الشباب ربما
يشككون وسلطه هؤلاء فقط يطالب بمساله انه
ربما لم يعد بالملكيه مكانا في بريطانيا
طبعا
البريطانيا قد تغيرت العالم تغير منذ
تنصيب الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
الامير الملك تشارلز الثالث كان يعني ما
يسمى متدربا على مدى سبعين عاما وشهد
التحولات الجيو استراتيجيه وتحولات العالم
يعني حينما وصل وصلت الملكه اليزابيث الى
السلطه على العرش اعتلت العرش في 53 كان
يعني ربما بدايه خريف
الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه حول العالم اليوم المؤسسه
الحاكمه هي يعني رئيسه حوالي 12 دوله حتى
الان نعم بريطانيا انسحبت من اتحاد
الاوروبي ولكنها تبقى في قلب اوروبا ولكن
ايضا نفوذها يتغير حول العالم نعرف ان
مثلا جزيره بربروس كانت قد استقلت قبل عام
هناك جامايكا وهناك دوله اخرى اعتقد انها
يعني
الدخول نعم لكي لا يكون هناك
لن يعود الملك الملك البريطاني رئيسا لها
كيف تغيرت شعبيه ملك تشارلز يعني
بالاحصاءات كانت تقول بانه شعبيته كانت
منخفضه لكنه نجح في رفع هذه الشعبيه برايك
كيف نجح في تغيير صورته
النمطيه لدى الكثير من البريطانيين
يعني بشكل او باخر هناك صعوبه اليوم ان
يتحول
ولي العهد الى ملك بين ليله وضحاها خصوصا
ولي عهد امضى حوالي 70 عاما متدربا كما
ذكرنا ولكن
هو يحاول عصرنه التاج البريطاني طبعا هذا
سيكون التحدي نعم
الملكه اليزابيث الراحله كانت قد اعادت
الحيويه الى بيت الوينسر وحكمهم وارتباطهم
الوثيق بالشعب واعتبرت ام الامه يعني
والده الامه اليوم التحدي كبير والعبء
ثقيل على الملك تشارلز الثالث يتمكن ان
يواصل نهج والدته نحن نعلم انه اتذكر في
نهايه التسعينات قامت هي وكانت سباقه الى
حسابات للقصر الملكي على وسائل التواصل
مثلا اليوم كل هذه المرحله والتغيرات
المتسارعه حول العالم
يعني يحاول تشارلز ان يكون قريبا كما كان
دائما من الشعب وان يكون يعني عفويا
وايضا كما رايناه بالامس نزل الى الشارع
وتحدث الى المواطنين هو
شخصيه اعتقد سيكون تحوله الداخلي من ولي
عهد وامير الى ملك سيكون صعب ولكننا ربما
لا نشهد هذا الجانب لانه سيطبع عمله
بالطبع الرسمي وتمسك بالاعراف ولكن الاصعب
عليه سيكون اخفاء شخصيته الشخصيه المهتمه
بالطبيعه هو مختلف تماما رغم انه يعني
يشبه والدته في امور لكنه يختلف عنها
تماما في امور اخرى الملكه اليزابي محمد
عرفت بانها يعني لديها حياه سياسي
باعتقادك انه هل سيسير على نهجها
وفيما يتعلق بشخصيته البعض يقول بانه
الملك تشارز الثالث في داخله انسان ربما
منفتح جدا لديه علاقات جيده بالعالم
العربي والثقافه الاسلاميه وباقي الثقافات
والديانات وكان هذا واضحا من خلال الحضور
مختلف الديانات وهذا امر مختلف في هذا
التتويج وبالتالي لكن شخصيته ليس ليس لديه
كاريزما كاريزما والده الراحله وبالتالي
الى اي مدى نجح في ايصال حقيقه الملك
تشارلز وبدا الناس يعرفونه عن قرب خصوصا
في بريطانيا
كما قالت
شقيقته الاميره ان استاذ ابراهيم
تشارلز معروف
لدى ععب البريطاني كبير صغيرهم فهو موجود
ومنذ ولادته ربما الطفل الاكثر يعني
التقاطا للصور واشرطه الفيديو في حياته من
اي شخص ثاني في العالم هذا لن يكون صعبا
عفويته هو مساله ما اذا كان سيهضمها
ستحضنها رسميات منصب الملك الان هذا هو
التحدي اعتقد لانه شخص يحب الضحك هناك
اشرطه كشف عنها القصر مؤخرا تظهره في
شبابه وهو في الجيش مثلا
ويمثل اسكتشات خرج وحاول التمثيل على
الخشب الكاميرا سرقت سرقت ابتسامه عريضه
الملك شارز قبل قليل وهو يستمع الى
الموسيقى وربما يعني جديه واهميه هذا
المقام الذي هو فيه وهذه اللحظات لكن لم
يمنع ذلك من ان يقوم
بالابتسام بابتسامه كانت واضحه ولافته
ربما اود ان اسالك قبل ان ننتقل الى
المرحله الثالثه عن موضوع الامير هاري اذا
لاحظت معي انه حتى كاميرات لم تلتقط صوره
قريبه للامير هاري كانت
نعم يعني كانت صور عامه ولم يتم التركيز
عليه
تعليقك على هذه الجزئيه تحديدا وملابسات
اصلا وصوله ومغادرته لهذه المراسم
يعني انا بشكل او باخر لاحظت انه جالس في
الصف الثاني وراء الثالث انه عمه نعم
حسب ما لاحظنا لكنه ضمن مقاعد الاسره
الملكي الاسره الملكيه
ليس من السهل على طبعا مساله تركيز
الكاميرات عليه ربما هناك بروتوكولات
حددها القصر كي لا تقوم
الكاميرات كاميرات من وجهه نظر صحفيه لانه
هو الحدث حضوره من عدمه كان حدثا اساسيا
وبالتالي ربما هناك بروتوكول ما كي لا يتم
التركيز ويتم التركيز على الملك ومساله
القسم وارتداء التاج والتفاصيل ومراحل
ولكن معروف عن تشارلز انه طلب من ولديه
يعني ابدت بالامر فيما بينكما انا يعني
الشخصين عزيزين عليه طبعا هو والد وهو في
هذا الشكل
يسعى للبقاء على الحياه كما نقل عنه
المؤرخون الملكيون هنا ولكنه مهتم جدا بان
يرابا الصدع او ان تنتهي المشاكل
والخلافات في منزله الخاص فهو يعني قريب
جدا من هاري وهري ذو شخصيه
يعني جدا جذابه كانت منذ رعان شبابه وصغره
ومساله تعلق والده به بالاضافه الى يعني
حبه الى الامير امير ويلز ولي عهده الا ان
مكانه هاري خاصه بنسبه للملك تشارلز
الثالث وايضا مكانه الميغن ماركل قال عنها
بانها مصنوعه من معدن لا يمكن لونه وهو
معجب بشخصيتها للغايه
كل ذلك هو لم يخفي سعادته يعني بوصول
الامير هاري فقط دعنا نشير الى ان ربما
المرحله الثالثه
المسح بالزيت المقدس
ستبدا او ربما بدات لا نعلم اذا كانت
انتهت الان
هي بالعاده استاذ ابراهيم خلف الستائر
بشكل خاص ربما لا نعرف اذا كانت هذه
الامبوله تشاهد معنى الشاشه هي التي تحتوي
على الزيت المقدس
كما تابعنا فان هذه الامبوله التي عليها
النسر هي التي تحتوي على الزيت المقدس
ربما بعد قليل سيتم المسح لا نستطيع تاكيد
ما اذا تمت هذه المرحله الثالثه ام لا
كونها تتم اذا تمت حسب ما يخبرني الزملاء
تمت وكما ذكرنا هي مرحله تتم بالخفاء
وهذه المرحله يخلع فيها الملك عباءه
التشريفات ويجلس على كرسي التتويج ثم يمسح
راسه وصدره بهذا الزيت الذي
تم اعداده في القدس وهو زيت له ربما
صفه دينيه مزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه
المرحله واهميتها واي المراحل تعتبر الاهم
والاكثر حسابا في هذه المرحله اذا يبدو ان
الان
يتم اذا يبدو انه لم تبدا مرحله المسح
بالزيت المقدس كما ذكرنا ستتم على هذا
الكرسي وستتم بسريه الان يتم اغلاق
يتم الان اغلاق
هذه المساحه لتتم عمليه المسح بالزيت بشكل
خاص
اذا كما توقعنا لم تبدا هذه المرحله بعد
سيمسح على راس الملك وصدره ويديه طبعا
الامبوله صنعت لاستخدامها اثناء التتويج
الملك تشارلز الثاني لكن الشكل الذي صنعت
فيه يعود الى عصور سابقه شباره هناك
اسطوره ربما انه هذا الزيت يرتبط يعني
بمعتقدات قديمه
وهناك خصوصيه هامه لهذه المرحله لماذا تتم
بهذا الخفاء ونحن الان نشاهد بانه يعني
يخلع عباءته
واستعدادا للدخول لكي يتم مسح الملك
تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا بعد ربما
مسح الزيت لماذا هذه
اللحظات لها خصوصيه وهل كانت على الدوام
تتم بهذا الشكل
يعني انا اعتقد انه مهما حاولنا عصرنه
الاساليب والاعراف الملكيه والتقاليد الا
ان هناك امور بقيت ثابته لا سيما ارتداء
التاج او وضع الصولجان او حمل الصولجان
والعصا وكل هذه الرجال المختلفه التي تطبع
العرش البريطاني لكن مساله المسح بالزيت
المقدسي هي جزء من التبريك الديني وكما
قلنا هو زعيم
للكنيسه الانجليكانيه وبالتالي يعني عليه
هناك طقوس ليس هناك من مهرب فيها ضمن ما
يسمى العرف وايضا
[موسيقى]
العلم الديني او الحيز الارتباط بالحيز
الديني والقيام
وهو اذا بتلاحظ والمشاهدين لاحظون قد خلعت
العباء
عن ملكه شعرز الثالث وبالتالي
ظهر شيء منها ولم تبقى كلها سريه ولكن
ربما عمليه المسح ستبقى سريه للغايه ولكن
فهذه يعني المباركات جزء من
تتويجه وتقويبه ملكا على بريطانيا وزعيما
للكنيسه ايضا اللافت بانه ربما بريطانيا
هي الدوله الوحيده التي ما زالت تتوج
ملكها بداخل كنيسه وبهذه البرامج بهذه
المراسم الدينيه الى اي مدى ربما يمثل هذا
خصوصيه بالنسبه لبريطانيا على هذا المستوى
ولماذا بريطانيا حافظت على هذه التقاليد
طوال هذه السنين محمد
يعني
الاستمراريه في بريطانيا امر نمى بشكل
يعني غير ربما مخطط له ولكن اذا اردت ان
تعرف شيئا عن بريطانيا وان دستورها غير
مكتوب وكل ما يجري فيها هو بالاعراف
وتقليد لما جرى في الماضي وهناك ذاكره
قويه ابقت على هذه العادات والاعراف
والتقاليد وكانت مناسبه مع نهج وفكر
هادئ هذه هذا هذه الجزيره التي في مرحله
من المراحل حكمت العالم ولكن تخيل ان يعني
منذ عام 1066
والعرش البريطاني او هذه العائلات بقيت
مترابطه وحكمت هذه البلاد
الى انه يعني المرحله الثالثه محمد مرحله
المسح بالزيت المقدس انتهت نشاهد
الملك تشارلز الثالث الان بعد ان تم مسح
راسه وصدره ويديه بهذا الزيت المقدس وتم
رفع الساتر الذي كان يحيط
بالكرسي الذي سيتم تتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث عليه والان يعود لارتداء ملابسه
من جديد ولا نعلم اذا كان سيرتدي العباءه
لكن الان
يعود يرتدي ملابسه بعد هذه المرحله الان
يقوم بارتداء هذه
العباءه الخاصه
وهو رداء دوله
طويل ومطرز لا هذا رداء اخر اذا يرتدي
رداء اخر ربما قبل
ان تستكمل مراحل
ومراسم تتويج الملك شاز الثالث لحظه صمت
لموسيقى الان نستمع للصوت الطبيعي من داخل
الكنيسه واستمليستر
اذا الان يجلس الملك تشارلز الثالث على
كرسي القديس ادوارد او كرسي التتويج هذه
اول مره نشاهد
الملك تشانز الثالث وهو يجلس على كرسي
القديس ادوارد هذا الكرسي الذي صنع قبل
1300 عام واستخدم في مراسم التتويج في
كنيسه وست مونستر
هذا الكرسي صنع بناء مشاهدينا على اوامر
الملك ادوارد الاول ملك انجلترا نتعرف
اكثر على رمزيه هذا الكرسي مع مراسل
العربيه مصطفى زارو مصطفى
هذه المرحله من اهم المراحل وتسبق التتويج
حدثنا عنها وعن رمزيه واهميه هذا الكرسي
التاريخي
[موسيقى]
هذا الكرسي كما ذكرت هو يعود لي 700 عام
تقريبا
وشهد العديد من مراسم التتويج خلال هذه
الفتره والملك تشارلز الثالث هو الملك
الاربعون الذي
يحظى بهذا التتويج على هذا
الكرسي العرش
في الكنيسه هذه الكنيسه التي ايضا هي يعني
مقبره ل 30 ملكا وملك
مروا على حكم هذه الدوله دوله انجلترا في
البدايه ومن ثم الى المملكه المتحده
بالطبع اربعون ملكا فقط هم من توجوا في
هذه الكنيسه بالتحديد بالتذكير بان هناك
ملكا وملكه على مر العصور منذ بدايه الحكم
الملكي في في هذا البلاد بالطبع فقط نشير
الى اننا نتابع الان دلاله
اذا كنت تتابع مع الصوره الان
تبدا المرحله الرابعه مرحله التنصيب
وتتضمن كما تحدثت الرجال التي تحتوي على
عدد من الادوات لو تشرح لنا الان يحمل
الملك تشارلز الثالث السيف
[موسيقى]
هذا هذا السيف هو يعني يحمل له دلاله خاصه
تتعلق بالقوه وايضا القدره على اختيار
الخير وبالتالي هناك صولجان سيتم يعني
منحهما وتقديمهما الى الملك تشارلز وهذه
ضمن الطقوس التي تشهدها هذه البلاد على مر
القرون الماضيه هي ادوات يتم تناولها
ويعني وتعمل على على في مراسم بشكل عام في
مراسم تتويج الملوك في المملكه المتحده
على مر هذه المده الزمنيه الطويله بالطبع
هذه الاحتفالات هذه يعني بعضها يعني يستمر
او يتمسك بالتقاليد العريقه التي شهدتها
البلاد بالاضافه الى ان هناك بعض
الاختلافات التي ادخلها الملك تشارلز
تماشيا مع العصر الحديث لهذه المملك هذه
الاختلافات بالرموز الملكيه ام انها هي
بقيت على حالها تتعلق ايضا بالكره الذهبيه
الملكيه والصولجان الملكيان وايضا السيف
هل هناك اختلاف في هذه الجزئيه ام بقيت
على حالها
ما ذكرته حقيقه هو يعني لم يتغير من
الناحيه طقوس الدينيه المتبعه في المملكه
المتحده يعني بالنسبه للكره الذهبيه او ما
يعرف
الجرم السماوي هو يعكس السلطه الدينيه
للملك تشارلز الثالث هو ايضا ملك هو ايضا
راس كنيسه انجلترا بالطبع كان هناك قسم
لرئيس اساقفه كانت
وهو ايضا قام بهذا القسم نيابا عن
الاساقفه الاخرين بالاضافه الى مشارك
مشاركه راهبات في مراسم هذا التتويج كما
تلاحظون على هذه الطاوله مجموعه من
الادوات التي يتم استخدامها على مر العصور
الماضيه الف سنه تقريبا على على مراحل
تتويج الملوك والملكات في المملكه
الاوروبي ما التاج الامبراطوري يعني الذي
الذي سيتم تتويج حفل ومراسم التنصيب به
نعم
هناك تاجان التاج الاول يعني سيتم ارتداه
مباشره بعد تنصيبه ملكا للبلاد ولكن عند
خروجه سيكون تاج اخر
سيرتديه عندما يستقل عربه العربه الذهبيه
التي يعود تاريخها الى اكثر من 200 عاما
من كنيسه
باتجاه قصر باكينغام هذه هذا المسار الذي
ربما سيقطعه يعني ما لاقل عن اربعه الاف
من الحرس الملكي والجنود من مختلف
سواء كانت من سلاح الجو الملكي المشاه
البحريه لانه الامير وليم الان انضم انضم
الامير ويليام الى هذه المراسم ويضع
هذه المرحله الرابعه اذا رسميا مرحله
التتويج ويشارك بها ولي العهد الامير
ويليام والده الملك تشارلز الثالث اذا هذه
المرحله بدات
تتضمن الان ارتداء هذه العباءه الثقيله
قيل بان هذه العباءه وزنها كبير
وعباء تم اعاده تدويرها من ربما
عباءات وملابس قديمه بريطانيه ملكيه نستمع
قليلا ثم نعود لك مصطفى
اذا جلس الملك
مرحله الرجاله مصطفى
ماذا تتضمن هل يمكن القول بانها انتهت انه
سيتم تسليمه الصولجنان والكره الذهبيه لم
نشاهده الان الكره الذهبيه كما تحدثنا
سيتم تسليمها للملك تشارلز الثالث كما
تحدثنا
وهذا هو الجزء الرابع من مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارل الثالث وهي المرحله
المسماه مرحله التنصيب
الان يتم تسليم الكره الذهبيه
وخاتم التتويج الذي نراه في الشاشه
وهذه كلها رموز ملكيه للكرامه
[موسيقى]
وسيتم تقديم
ايضا الصولجان
ذي الحمامه
وصولجان اخر
للملك بالاضافه الى كل هذه الرموز
وهذه القفازات الملكيه التي يرتديها الان
الملك تشارلز الثالث
طبعا
قناه العربيه ستواكب
هذه المراسم
وسيرافقكم على راس الساعه الزميل نايف
الاحمري تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا وفرجه ممتعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات